Coucou !
Après les Parisiens, après les Marseillais, après les Anglais,
Cette fois-ci nous sommes en Suisse!
Alors vous connaissez le principe,
On se prend des panneaux, des poteaux, des murs, dans le but de tester la bienveillance des gens.
Cette fois-ci on a voulu renouveler un peu le concept, pour pas que ce soit redondant, et on a fait appel à un guest.
A un invité un peu spécial du web :
SQUEEZIE !
Ah non, moi c’est le Grand JD!
Le grand JD, ouais c'est ce que j'ai dit !
Ouais c’est ce que tu as dit!
Julien est ce que t'es chaud ?
OUAIS J'SUIS CHAUD !
Mais j’ai un peu peur quand même…
C’est normal, t’as peur de te faire mal.
Cri de guerre !
3, 2 ,1. C'est PARTI !
Oh putain c'est de la merde !
Ah putain y à plein de merde !
C'était pas une bonne idée.
Première chute : échec.
D'la merde.
Ah putain !
Qu'est ce qui s'est passé ?
J’étais en train de dabber et je me suis pris la vitre, là.
Je sens plus mon bras droit...
Oh, elle appelle les pompiers.
Putain, elle appelle les pomplars!
Les pompiers, c’est le 4, c’est les pompiers?
Là je dabbe depuis hier 14h.
Attendez, je vois si j’arrive à dabber.
Oh oui, oui, elle lui met un truc sur la tête.
Elle le met en PLS.
Et vous vous appelez comment ?
Squeezie.
C'est une connerie, regardez.
On s'est fait grillé !
Ok on s'en va c'est fini. Reste là toi, ne bouge pas, ne bouge pas.
C’est pas notre ami, nous on filmait là et on l’a vu donc on l’a filmé parce qu’on trouvait ça marrant.
Sauf que moi je veux pas être là-dessus alors vous m’enlevez tout de suite ça.
Vous n’aimez pas Youtube?
J’en ai rien à foutre de Youtube.
Ah d'accord, ok.
Vous êtes suisse Madame ?
Oui je suis suisse. Ça vous dérange?
Ah non pas du tout !
Vous enlevez la partie où je suis ou j’appelle les flics.
Voilà, supprimer.
Vous savez quoi, je sais même pas où il est le truc.
Et bah alors, vous êtes doué en plus.
Il s’est trompé de panneau, j’peux pas vous dire mieux.
Vous avez fait fort!
Il a été surpris par la voix du mec.
Est-ce que vous pouvez me prêter votre bob?
Il lui demande son chapeau.
Vous pouvez me prêter votre bob, j’ai un peu mal à la tête.
Allez, je vais le prendre.
Il a une obsession avec les couvre-chefs.
Ça vous dérange si je garde le bob?
Non, j’y tiens trop.
J’comprends. Merci.
Allez, bonne chance
J’crois qu’on peut dire que le Grand JD a réussi son premier impact.
Ouais, premier impact réussi.
On lui avait dit de parler de Pokémon.
Ouais, parce qu’il a un peu peur en impro, donc.
Le gars a juste dit Pokémon. Il a juste dit le mot.
Pokémon.
Alors, c’était comment?
C’est bien, très bien. C’est super mec!
T'as bien fait.
Bonne répartie.
Vous vous êtes couchés, c’est ça?
Vous êtes couché, je suis debout.
C’est Inception, on est à 90 degrés inversés.
Qu’est-ce que vous foutez dans ma cuisine?
Je suis debout, c’est bon je suis debout.
C’est bon, c’est bon, c’est bon. Ah, ah, aaah!
Bloqué !
Wow, wow, wow, wow!
Sortez-moi de là bordel !
Oh il l’a très bien tapé!
Il fait pas le chat du coup?
Il fait complètement le chat.
Il s’est frotté, il s’est frotté à sa jambe !
Il va lui en mettre une !
Bonjour maman !
T’as bien changé mais t'es toujours aussi douce.
Je t'aime.
Il est perdu le gars !
Il comprend pas ce qu’il vient de se passer, oh la la!
Oh, il a bien tapé, ils s’en battent les couilles encore!
Oh elle est parfaite.
Je suis au paradis.
Nous vous êtes à Genève, mon cher.
Oui, je suis au paradis fiscal de la Suisse à Genève.
Mais pourquoi vous êtes rentré dans ce panneau, là?
On peut dire que je suis tombé dans le panneau.
Il a pris une clope le con.
Vous êtes anti-tabac, c’est pas votre problème.
C’est typiquement ce qu’il faut quand on va mal, c’est la clope.
Bah on donne bien du schnaps c’est encore pire.
Les gens ils sont coinços, hein globalement.
Complètement!
Vous êtes tombé sur la mamie qu’est la moins coincée du quartier.
Pour moi vous êtes pas une mamie, pour moi vous êtes une pornstar.
J’vais là-bas moi.
Bah alors on y va ensemble.
C'est parti.
Aller.
Vous savez, l’amour est global.
Absolument.
Non, je peux pas y croire!
Vous êtes vivant, vous auriez pu avoir un trauma.
Ou un bleu.
Oh ils s’en battent les couilles.
Ils sont passés, ils ont tout vu, ils s’en battent les couilles.
Il a maté le gars.
Olàlà, mais c’est fou!
Y a un mec il s’en est battu les couilles.
Il était là.
Oh c'est fou !
Ah bah voilà!
La seule personne qui pourrait m’aider c’est cette magnifique enfant.
Tu m’aides à me relever?
C’est trop bien, c’est trop bien, un enfant.
Regarde, donne-moi la main, t’es un ange, un ange sur terre.
La conclusion, faut la tirer de vous même.
Merci !
C’est toi, t’es la meilleure.
Je suis réellement ému !
Attendez, reculez, reculez-tous, tout le monde recule!
Tout le monde recule, svp!
Ouais, c’est bon, c’est bon. Merci beaucoup!
Merci.
JD a réussi sa chute.
Il est des nôtres, il a réussi sa chute comme les autres!
Vous pouvez m’expliquer ce que vous avez?
Non bah là je courrais pour attraper le bus et j’me suis pris le truc, je l’avais pas vu devant ma gueule.
Vous pouvez me passer votre béquille?
Attendez, je vais prendre l’autre.
Il va partir en courant avec.
Vous vous appelez?
Sylvie.
A chaque fois il dit Sylvie!
Dans tous les épisodes, il dit Sylvie.
Je vais y aller, non mais c’est gentil, je vais y aller.
Au revoir.
Passez-moi vos béquilles une deuxième fois s’il vous plaît.
Qu’est-ce qu’on fait là?
Non, non mais attendez là.
Merci de m’avoir essuyé la bave.
Attendez, je vais essayer d’y aller sans me prendre le truc.
3. 2. 1.
Oh merde!
J’arrive pas à sortir de cette zone.
J’pars là!
Non, non, non!
Ah putain encore une fois!
Ok, vous êtes vraiment parfait.
Regardez, c’est une caméra cachée.
Vous avez un petit mot pour Youtube?
Faites chier!